foreign
people welcome to a live edition of I
don't understand the commentaries in
studio we're all here we got drinks uh
we're having drinks we all have drinks
so many drinks we love drinks folks
alcoholic drinks we're talking about
um dungeons of dragons hat honor monkeys
today then we're going to uh show you
some outtakes uh we'll do some q a so
put your questions in the chat and then
we'll clue you in with next week's film
uh at the very end I will refuse I will
not tip you off early I always do it's
based on a game it's Mario
I just get so excited you got that Roman
Roy thing like do I have to fire you
well now I've said it you're fired
uh we
um also released a fast and furious by
the Numbers this morning on this very
same channel find out exactly how many
times they say family uh how many man
hugs how many Coronas there's there's
all the steps for the back of your Fast
and Furious baseball cards yeah
um check that out on this same channel
so Dungeons and Dragons honor among
Thieves
um a film that had so many strikes going
against it for me personally going in
not a d d guy uh the trailers look
terrible I guess there's just two just
those are really the only two you need
yeah
and damn it if this movie didn't win me
over almost instantly it was really just
a delight from start well I don't say
from start to finish it's not Flawless
but it was really fun and I did not
expect that what were your what were
your expectations versus reality on this
one well so with this one it was
um I already because I love DND so much
like when I first heard that they was
they were doing this I'm like yeah every
10 years we're gonna get one of these
and it's always going to be terrible and
no one's gonna get it and then when I
heard that it was the game night dudes I
was like okay now this is looking
interesting and cool and the first
trailer came out and I was like oh was
this a red wizard notice like what are
we doing and uh and then yeah and then
everyone you know obviously I hang out
with a bunch of um ttrpgers and a bunch
of like d d playing crew and everyone
was coming back and being like this is
really good and it's like are you saying
that so that everyone sees it online and
they were like no I'm serious like it is
really good and I watched and I was like
well gosh darn it hot diggity dog I was
in full disbelief from the very
beginning because you know people like
Ted lasso like there's
I I saw Guardians uh three this weekend
and and that on top of this it's like
you know as much as we bash on the sort
of the Marvel formula and how
predictable these kinds of movies are
and how the sort of fatigued we are on
that kind of like snarky Adventure Heist
sensibility you know if you re if you do
it right if you write it and it's funny
and you really put like care and thought
and yeah characters you have a white
Chris front and center you put a white
Chris in there when they belong no but
it's like you can still make these old
formulas work as tired as they might be
if you just do the work you know if you
like if the script is funny if the
characters are Charming if you kind of
figure out the world everything Clicks
in this and it is it's a lot of fun even
though it's the sort of thing that yeah
I think shouldn't work or normally
doesn't work right if the Marvel formula
is uh action plus comedy plus plus IP
there's a lot of Brit there's a lot of
Wiggles in action and comedy to be good
or bad and I thought that the comedy was
like way better than expected and the
action was like okay they're like
they're trying things this doesn't look
exact this doesn't play out exactly like
they did some really cool stuff like
that all the hands all the hand stuff
all the hand stuff all the hand stuff at
the end was really really cool and again
an unexpected way because and we talk
about got this the goo flicking problem
the third act goo yeah that always shows
up in a lot of these movies and they
found a way to degoo this movie and that
way is Owl Bear yeah there's no there's
thought put into like how would these
different and I mean that that makes
sense in a D and D world that you would
put that kind of thought into like how
different characters would use magic and
magical items or whatever but it just it
does feel like the the thought was put
in they took the time during developing
this and thinking about it to really
make it specific to the world of uh you
know D and D and Forgotten Realms and
and that that reality instead of having
it feel more like a morbius or an
Uncharted or one of these other kinds of
movies that we watch where it feels a
little slap Dash thrown together generic
right and I think that it also helps
that with something like this you can
tell that these dudes actually play D D
sure you can tell that this is something
that they you know this is like a love
letter to a thing that they already play
and if not then I don't know why they
already made a board game movie if they
don't like games but there's I'm very
much looking forward to settlers of
Qatar
what there's resources baby I I like
that they don't put a fine point on it
but there is the sense that it does feel
a bit like these are people in our world
playing d and d and we are seeing their
campaign right
existed the urge to pan out and show you
yeah Will Ferrell exactly and like you
know that there was a stage where at
least they got that studio note like
should we pull back and see the kids
playing this game and like they didn't
do that but there is still that sense of
like a new character to show up and like
tell you their backstory like a car like
a person would if they were playing d d
and had a new character and I like that
element yeah and being able to explain
all the different classes and blah blah
blah I could really talk about like how
much this movie did right for like yeah
and now we have to talk about what I did
wrong yeah and the characters who have
like that that sort of like they sound
like a dungeon master like giving you
the backstory like Rajesh Jean page has
a few speeches like that where he's
giving you the sort of exposition but in
the way that a non-player character
would yeah I mean but as like a d d
non-player it didn't I didn't find it
distracting right or obsequious for them
to just keep doing dropping references
even though like you know I know what
Baldur's Gate is from games I know what
ice when Dale is like I've heard these
things right also these tropes have like
infected every other fantasy yes
throughout the world
yeah let's watch it Australia for a
dungeon dragon's hat hat
Jonathan I'm not I'm never gonna stop
[Music]
in a world of high fantasy low comedy
and special effects wankery a big Studio
adaptation of a beloved nerd franchise
will turn out not awful kind of fun
actually funny okay lock the doors
nobody leaves this room until we figure
out how this happened Dungeons and
Dragons hat uh I mean honor among
Thieves
let's call uh let's call it for a thing
that looks bad that we think is gonna
has a chance of being good for the rest
of let's say the year is there anything
that like what like a red notice that's
gonna surprise us like uh ooh do you
think like I'm excited for extraction
too ah I'm kind of excited I don't think
the first distraction very much just an
action movie full out not a red notice
so though I I I I am looking forward to
extraction too but I don't I don't think
that's surprising like I think
extraction two is gonna be cool
mean Craven the hunter we're thinking
that that could be uh shock the world I
think I think that's a real movie yeah
yeah I don't know I mean I think that's
that till 2024 though maybe is that this
oh yeah well that's my pick because well
it sounds terrible on the surface these
are the same brain Geniuses that brought
us Venom 2 and morbius so comedy
intentional or unintentional
potentialism yeah yeah okay yeah I you
know I we got a clip yesterday it it
does not seem that promising but I'm I'm
not totally giving up on it yet Indiana
Jones and the dial of Destiny that's my
pick it's not gonna be as good it's not
but I mean nothing what's as good as
Raiders like um I like mangled and and
the the clip that they released
yesterday I I did not love but like I'm
not ready to count that one out entirely
yet a lot of talent associated with it I
love the character Indiana Jones so I'm
holding out hope that that one surprises
us yeah that I'm I'm hoping that that's
going to be really good but that's one
where I'm also going in with
the next best choice is to weaken to
Bernie's him through an action adventure
so you know put the Fedora over his eyes
and then just kind of bring him to do it
yes come on swing them from set piece to
set piece uh okay let's keep watching
memory hole Dungeons and Dragons 2000
and if you remember the cartoon your
kids are waiting for you to pick them up
from school now strap in for a film that
takes a wild new approach what if a
Marvel movie were as Charming as it
thinks it is with cool magic
good jokes
and action with some thought put into it
so what if they drop a magic Sky Beam at
the end it's been a while since we had a
good Sky beam I missed you old friend
you know we did get a sky beam in Black
Adam I think that's we're having a
second Renaissance of Sky beams uh you
know every 10 years every the kids
discover and ReDiscover Sky beams just
like Nirvana you know in many ways the
sky beam never left it's been serving
the same great quality third act so hold
on Sky beam was inside you well yeah
what's your favorite Sky beam is it um
is it a Sci-Fi blue laser Sky beam um
more of a magical Skype I don't feel
like you could oh go ahead I'm sorry oh
no no no you go I was gonna say uh the
the
bizarre Justice League uh like
radioactive Orange Sky what I like yeah
I like the Justice League one and and
others if it's ilk that are being slowly
orbited by rocks yeah
around the edges I feel like I feel like
Man of Steel and then Justice League
like Snyder kind of does own the sky but
like he's he's our preeminent Sky beam
Suicide Squad yeah Suicide Squad and
that one that was like a dirty Sky beam
like that was this guy that looked like
it was made of mold the DC EU home tone
to the great Skies do you prefer Sky
beam that's coming from a device or a
portal
an Einstein Rosen Bridge that's the best
guy
okay yeah well that's your top Sky beam
store let's do a sky beam tier list
video can we do it can we do it by the
Numbers guys most powerful Sky beams and
this is how our meetings are yeah yeah
yeah yeah I think I like that gold uh
okay keep going
suck there's only one Hollywood Chris
you should call he's got the charm the
sex appeal the magic voice
my God you saved friendship with this
song
he don't trust you when you left me
Pine's got the range baby show me just
one thing that Chris Pratt is better at
except making money
uh we do have speaking by the Numbers an
episode dropping perhaps next week about
Hollywood's best Chris yeah any any uh I
I think we know your favorites I think
everyone here is favorite is either
Evans or pine right I mean everyone's
favorite around the globe should be
Evans or pine that's really the
competition yeah
with Pratt people out there well if you
have your if you want to throw your
predictions down for uh the categories
are gonna be uh like best Chris in a
fight best Chris romantically and then
um like box office and critical yeah
kind is best Chris romantically I think
well sure but do you do you have any
predictions for overall I think Pine is
dreamiest Chris but I think Evans is
your box office King Chris okay yeah
we're Pratt maybe now that I'm thinking
well there's a different there's
different winners for average box office
and you know yeah well Pratt's got those
Jurassic films on top of the Marvels so
that puts him up he's a serious
contender in terms of us no he's got the
Mario yeah and now with Mario the answer
may surprise you next week
um yeah but I think everybody just likes
Evans and pine more yeah yeah at this
point I mean if we could go back if they
ever do the Burt Macklin FBI uh film
then maybe Pratt comes back yo I just
really uh
yeah I uh I really Lake um I realized I
think all of us did that we didn't
really like Chris Pratt like we liked
Andy Dwight yeah exactly I think that
was kind of the thing it's like oh no
that was really just a mouse rat fan all
right keep going
Michelle Rodriguez as wait wait get this
a tough lady
finally she gets to show up she's got
her fighting skills and a tiny man
fetish they'll join Simon a whiz with no
rizz
we know what words mean yeah yeah nailed
it yeah Doric the Druid the only one
without any character development
because she's too busy getting done
[Music]
and the Paladin Zang who is clearly an
NPC that the DM dropped in to get those
idiots unstuck and back on the main
quest line they're much about that
advising and strategy pretty much
everything together they'll face off
against Hugh Grant who's now just a good
bloke who plays villains instead of back
in the 90s when it was the opposite and
the red wizard for that I don't know
until the big bad Rose in for the sequel
nearly come please let Jeremy Irons play
this guy in the sequel he deserves
another crack at this
for an adventure they're massively over
leveled for
[Music]
featuring tea with so much plot armor
their fiercest foe spawns in with
diabetes
where even the one weapon in the entire
fantasy universe that can actually hurt
someone's display it's nothing I can do
does it
[Music]
play during a Dungeons and Dragons
campaign do you just have to go home
just have to leave um so if you you know
in some places they'll be they'll you'll
be able to be revived or you can take a
long rest or something like that but if
you're playing the kind of game where if
you die you die you make a new character
yeah and then so they just show up like
yeah then you're like hey guys hey can I
join your party yeah yeah they're just
like oh yeah you go to a pub and like
you see a mysterious woman and like that
that's your new character that's
literally exactly what happened yeah so
it's like in beer fest when uh yes
I don't know if you notice all rules for
Dungeons and Dragons are based on
you make you make a new name you may you
give your new guy a new name love beer
fest
okay forget Mario next week be very
underrated all right uh keep going it's
rated
the only way that can be defeated is by
constantly forgetting magic exists and
their extremely magical world just
talking the time stuff
oh God magic that's right
see this is why you always need to bring
a palette in but they just let theirs
walk away
is part of the movie yeah over the rock
so if you want to take the game that's
quietly been influencing all pop culture
in the background for decades and do it
justice on the big screen Why not pick
the team that already turned a nerdy
game night into a hilarious action
comedy guys make sure you get a piece of
this cheese wait don't tell me you
haven't seen Game Night what oh you have
to see it in fact you should pause this
video and go watch it right now there's
no pausing don't worry we'll wait one
two three
the dog is so good right uh where was I
oh yeah Dungeons and Dragons It's good
I've had Paramount and stove oh uh well
I bet E1 and Hasbro are celebrating okay
someone needs to explain to me how
success Works in this industry so story
369 by Chris Pine Vice news new if he's
lawful good why did he steal the movie
The Justice Society Anna Moore Oh the
Hugh Grant a thief wizards of shaverly
place every franchise needs a Thanos
Gone Girl Mini Cooper A.I art and bad
Dragon Google it while you're at work
no dude don't do that yeah
hi are you a movie wife does your
husband insist on Staring at you why
sheets one for your life I'll bang it
you're about to die
you're in a flashlight you're already
dead you are 100 already dead you're
being remembered tenderly sorry it's
over for you okay Black Sheets get Black
Sheets I was saying this to Danielle uh
on our on our drive here uh I was
positive like for most of the movie that
Sophia lillis the the Doric the actress
played dork was also playing the evil
red wizard lady okay I just thought it
was the same actors and I was like this
is gonna be a great twist nobody I'm so
clever for seeing this coming did not
happen totally different white ladies I
just got them mixed up also I I I have
to wonder do you think that like
Michelle Rodriguez was like calling Vin
Diesel from set oh for tips yeah I I
feel like well let's let's move on well
let's do I'll take some questions we
have a great uh Vin Diesel related D
question yes uh let's run those outtakes
who's just here to glower until the big
bad Rose in for the sequel
but your work here is nearly complete
every franchise needs a Thanos and a
monster's manual worth of creatures here
to make DND fans do the Leo meme ooh
gelatinous kids
story
mandolin Manuel Miranda the mandolinian
The Bard identity suck it gas gear womb
and the Barbarian a Bridger 10.
[Applause]
magic
elf Improvement my name is Simon and I
like casting I just took a DNA test
turns out I'm 100 that Albert peace girl
Nancy Druid flirty Rotten Scoundrels
they Queen Living Dead Girl hey what's
up
red wedding Hood she can be a real [__]
don't call me daughter
one Dungeons and two dragons it's true
Role Models Once Upon a Time in feyron
fast and the fantasy Ocean's twenty
sided die
we
have a good time
on to the questions uh Adam Halbert says
out of the 2023s major live-action
Hollywood Chris movies wow how is it my
favorite Evans my favorite Evans is
terrible in the worst one ghosted I
think you're the only one who saw ghosts
oh man oh my God ghosted is when I talk
about like red notices and that ghosted
is exactly the thing I'm complaining
about like I'm not saying it's like the
the the the exact like everything a red
notice does necessarily but it's like
that idea of like the laziness and the
sort of the hackiness and the sort of
the fact that they never look like
they're actually in any location they're
obviously just in a warehouse in Burbank
and like the you know the the kyber pass
is being animated behind them like it's
every red node is sin in one movie
that's a it's a shame and you think that
just the the Chris Evans Anna De armas
pairing could be enough to be how do
they have no chemistry in this movie
yeah there is absolutely not in there
it's supposed to be like this like kind
of like love at first sight like thing
and he's clinging and kneading it it
doesn't even it doesn't even make sense
on that most basic level because it's
like she's irritated by him right away
but also she just agrees to like hang
out with him right like why she there's
no way these two people would end up
spending time together anyway
got it well yeah
you'd think there'd be just the the
leads though like in the leads would
would take you through it because what
was that one with the it's like the
romance writer and Channing Tatum like
Sandra Bullock oh the lost city it's
like this is a bad movie but I'm still
enjoying watching
chemistry yeah the the jokes in the lost
city are like 10x ghosts like so much
better like it's so much funnier just as
at a at its core that's a shame disaster
all right uh Bruins fan uh 11 44. uh we
don't need lights who needs lights here
yeah it's slightly brighter but yeah I
appreciate it we gotta change that timer
yeah we just sit here too long
um so Burns man uh Vin Diesel was very
jealous of Michelle Rodriguez when he
heard of her Casting what role should he
play in the sequel we gotta get diesel
in there yeah we've got it then should
really be there even if it's like a
grudish you know he's a monster have him
come in and be the person that says
Jonathan
why do you think of like the the role
that Reggie I'm not saying don't bring
back zenk in a few your one because I
like that character bringing back but
that role like a guy who comes in for
like a scene or two helps out the party
with his Superior skills and then
disappears yeah that could be rotate
like you could bring in different dudes
you could do that every time Street
shark yeah
and shark I mean I think he should get
him doing that little dance to Sam Smith
yeah he should be the last witch hunter
because that was already inspired by his
d d character he should just be his d d
character in d d that'd be great like
literally like what we were saying like
they they're at a bar and Vin Diesel's
character is there like I just think I
should join your adventuring party for
this Quest man what a nerd
uh James Bud says everything needs to be
a Trilogy so this this creative team's
done a murder night game and d and d so
it's the third type of board game
complete the trilogy settlers all
resources baby all resources
I would also see a Stratego movie if
these guys did it like like a Napoleonic
War comedy some of those dudes yeah
James Bond is saying don't leave out
Claudia with a chance of meatballs with
the best Sky beam I mean that's like the
the device is shooting off food but I
guess there's a beam at the center I
mean it's a it's a it's a comedic Sky
beam yeah it's a comedy take on the sky
beam yeah
um let's see uh are we gonna do a good
Omens trailer before season two did
anybody watch season one of good I liked
it you know yeah is that season aren't
they
like no it's season two coming with
something else yeah this is the Amazon
one that's based on the Neil Gaiman
Terry Pratchett book with uh David
Tennant and um
Michael Sheen Michael Sheen they're the
Angel and the devil and they're working
together to prevent the apocalypse and
everyone's waiting for them to make out
right yeah but I think season two is
like season one was based on the book
season two is gonna like expand the
story in new ways because they already
adapted the book I like Manila Neil
stuff so I'll I'll have to it's fun I I
like season one I don't know if it was
popular they're still doing American
Gods I like that no that's canceled
um MJ pretz is Bradley Cooper the unsung
hero of this thing his Cameo was
delightful I agree that was a nice Cameo
it was like an unexpectedly heartfelt
scene about people who are different
places in life and then I don't know he
almost made me cry he's just like she
doesn't make me cry all the time I don't
worry about where she's leaving I was
like oh tiny Bradley tiny bread and then
I'll also Bradley feeling also a
standout very emotional turn in
Guardians three Bradley okay what a year
for Bradley Cooper plus he's got his
Leonard Bernstein movie in December yeah
is he gonna be tiny in that too well I
mean Leonard brixty not not a not a
super tall man I don't know how tall is
he was
um and then we'll end with this uh Jeff
Nicholas asking what's y'all's alignment
I assume that means like lawful chaotic
neutral yeah I mean everyone likes to
think of themselves as good right
yeah I like to think I'm chaotic good
yeah I think we're all chaotic good
you're probably oh really lawful I was
gonna say yeah lawful neutral I feel
like like I'm not breaking though I
don't want to get in any trouble but
like yeah okay cheat a little bit get
away with it you know I'm gonna sneak
around neutral that's neutral right
that's neutral I think every bad person
evil lawful evil would be like I'm gonna
try to get away with bad stuff as long
as I know I can get away with it that's
not I think it's more lawful neutral
like if I could cut a corner now and
again I wouldn't say no
you can't align yourself yeah um I tried
one that's like writing your own CV yeah
yeah uh so use your left hand to align
yourself feel different stranger uh we
will be back next week uh same time same
place for another game based movie you
already gave it away see if you can
guess which one it
won it it's right The Last Starfighter
we'll be back next year
[Music]